his determination to stay camped outside
the Iranian embassy in London whilst his
jailed wife Nazneen continues with her
hunger strike nearly 3,000 miles away
remains resolute but after a week
without food by his own admission
Richard Ratcliffe is feeling tired he
just gets slower praying reunited with
love Julia Craig Amy and Ella from
Cambridge with just tea and water for
sustenance
Richard Ratcliffe has been here day and
night this one is dear Richard I think
about you and your family often I hope
that you and Nazneen will be reunited
soon the leaves hammer roll and that's
from Norwich his Energy's coming from
the support of people who simply feel
the pain of a man who hasn't seen his
wife and child for three years from
Belfast looks like there's about 13 and
it's probably this is the most we've had
picked up this is how it began last
Saturday when Richard accompanied by his
family arrived at the Embassy his
relatives including his mother Barbara
have between them being monitoring
Richards fast my primary thing this week
and while he does is he's watching him
like a hawk and then our children and
their friends are doing the nighttime
shift we're not going to leave him alone
will do as long as it takes
there has been a growing stream of
visitors including complete strangers
through lava like this woman who made a
detour from her London engagement to
deliver a bunny rabbit for Richards
daughter Gabriella who remains in Tehran
with her grandparents I put her in his
wife story and we had no idea how to get
in touch and so when I saw he was at the
Embassy Apple and we're coming I was
desperate to come all of this goodwill
is probably deeply annoying for the
Iranians earlier in the week Richard's
friends filmed when embassy staff put up
steel barriers on the pavement next to
him the Iranians jailed Nazneen for
spying in 2016 since then richard has
been a constant thorn in their side
protesting her innocence what was going
on with the barrier in your mind
was it an attempt to just kind of train
intimidated I think they were turning
drivers of the pavement about to be
removed away where they can't see me the
whole point is that this email
bridging liberal here in your face to
make the commotion you should we should
recognize the suffering you agree you
produce steadfast in his support for his
wife whatever the Iranians do or say
Richard Ratcliffe won't stop the hunger
strike until nazaneen-e knows Lisa
Holland Sky News